και πολύ πάραπολύ φεα ημουσία γανα δημιουργήσει μια σχεδώ καινούρια πολύ η λεμεσώς έχει ιστορία
έχει μια μεγάλει παράδωσι στην λογοτεχνία να μην ξεχναμε οδίο μεγαλύτερο σπίτης κατεμένα ο βασίλης
ομιχαηλίδης εργάστηκή στη λεμεσό έγραψε όλα τα μεγάλα του έργαστή λεμεσό παόπου κατατα αλο χώρο
καιπέραντούτου φυσικά είχαμε παραπλο πίτες καιλογοτέχνες και ναθυμίσω ότι το πρώτο περιοδικό λόοτεχνικό γρα αυτή
και στη λεμεσ σε πλέρεια φυμοτική το χλια νιακόσακοθέρα απότενχουρμούζει και άλλους συδεργάτες εσς κπ
από τε ν τελευταία αφρά που γράψανα επινήση αφού πάμε πρι ότι γράφαα έχω υκδώσει
έναστην αλάδα έναβιυιαράκι με γιαπονέζεικπίση αϊκού η απονές ι κυπίσ είναι μια δύσκολη να μια
δύσκολη φόρμα όχι δύσκολιπίς είναι δύσκολη φόρμα γιατί περιορίζεται σε πέεευτά και πέτε συλαβές εδεκα
εφτασυλαές και εκεί πρέπει να βάλεις ότι θέλεις να πεις και έχω γράψη και άλλα
ποιήματα τα οποία αλλο έχω δημοσιες